Speaker 1: We have to start today with yet another
defeat or failure for the so-called Anti-woke
movement. It's really important to understand that
all of these folks in the current American right
wing who insist that America is embroiled in a
culture war around which apparently the survival
of the country depends, which I don't believe for
a second. One of the things that they will rarely,
if ever, admit, is that the war is extraordinarily
one sided in the sense that it is the retrograde
right wing that has chosen to fight these battles.
And it has been the left having no choice but to
react and say, Hey, the things you're asking for
don't make sense. The battles you're choosing to
fight are battles that we now have to get involved
in, not because we want to, but because you are
trying to discriminate and under the law create
multiple tiers of people and so on and so forth.
But they are suffering defeat after defeat. I told
you earlier this week that the Tennessee anti-drug
bill has been blocked. It does appear to violate
the First Amendment. We talked about a new Gallup
study that finds that support for gay marriage
is as high as ever in the United States. The Utah
book ban has backfired and actually led to the
Bible being banned. And even the Book of Mormon is
now being looked at to say, hey, wait a second,
if we're banning sexual and violent content,
don't these books also have to be banned? So it
has been failure after failure after failure,
and we now have yet another defeat. A federal
judge has blocked Florida's ban on gender
affirming care for minors in a narrow ruling
and has stated gender identity is real. The
Associated Press reports saying gender identity
is real. A federal judge temporarily blocked
portions of a new Florida law that bans trans
minors from receiving puberty blockers ruling
Tuesday that the state has no rational basis
for denying patients treatment. They have many
irrational bases, but no rational basis. This is
a preliminary injunction from Judge Robert Hinkle,
who says three trans kids can continue receiving
treatment. The lawsuit challenges the law that
Governor Ron DeSantis signed the same week
he announced a run for president. Hinkle said
the elephant in the room should be noted at the
outset. Gender identity is real. The record makes
this clear. Despite the defense admissions, there
are those who believe that cisgender individuals
properly adhere to their natal sex and that
trans individuals have inappropriately chosen
a contrary gender identity, male or female, just
as one might choose whether to read Shakespeare or
Grisham. This is extraordinarily important. Now,
I want to we've talked about so many different
aspects of this. And of course, this is only a
preliminary injunction or as Mike Pillow says
of Eliminare injunction, regardless of how you say
it, this is only a preliminary injunction and it's
possible that the law may be upheld. I want to
talk about the religious component here with many
of these issues, because when we talk about the
abortion bans, the attempts to ban gay marriage,
the attempts to justify discrimination on the
basis of sexual orientation or gender identity,
often there are religious justifications that
are cited. Now, we could talk about how these
anti-woke positions aren't actually the most
popular positions we could. There's all sorts
of things we could talk about, but because we've
done that already, let me briefly address the
religious component to this. We often see
defenses or justifications for these laws
on religious grounds. And when I say religious
grounds, I'm talking about Christianity. And
when I say Christianity, I'm mostly talking about
evangelical Christianity, that those are that's
the strong religious movement in this country
that is pushing most of this anti-woke stuff. I am
wondering whether it would be interesting to fight
some of these laws on the basis that they vow
that they violate the religious beliefs of others.
I'll give you an example. According to Jewish law,
human life begins at birth, not at
conception. It begins at the first breath.
The majority of foundational Jewish texts say a
fetus does not attain personhood until birth. So
Judaism does not consider that life begins
at conception, but rather at the moment of
of delivery. Could I or any other Jewish person
sue saying that anti-abortion bills violate their
religious beliefs? This has been mentioned before
and it would be an extraordinarily interesting
path to approach, to take to approach fighting
some of these laws. Now, similarly, we can look at
gender identity in many Jewish belief systems. It
is recognized that there are six distinct genders,
including male, female and intersex identities.
Reform Judaism Advocates for Transgender Justice
affirms the value of all people, regardless of
gender identity. Now, of course, you could find
Orthodox Judaism, which would have a different
view. But is there not an argument to be made
that these anti-trans laws of all kinds,
whether it comes to gender affirming care
or whether it comes to pronouns or whether it
comes to bathrooms or whatever the case may be,
violates the religious beliefs and practices of
many Jewish movements, groups of Jews, sects,
maybe they would be called. I think that there is
something here, and I know it's been mentioned in
passing by some rabbis, if they are going
to go the religious direction with this,
I would like to explore fighting them on
the same grounds. It's not going to be me
necessarily as a non-religious person. I consider
myself culturally, ethnically and call a narrowly
Jewish for lack of a better term. But this really
should be looked at. And the if we want to find a
silver lining in this entire culture war, war
that the right has unleashed upon the country,
it's that they don't actually seem to have
the majority of the country on their side,
and also that they don't seem to have the law on
their side when it comes to what they're pushing.